l'ordre
peut-il émerger sans autorité quelle est
la nature du vivant qu est-ce qu à
prendre
il s'agit là de grandes questions
philosophiques et pourtant aujourd'hui
on va voir que ces questions des
réponses mathématiques plus mystérieux
encore ces réponses ont été découvertes
et de manière indépendante par des
mathématiciens et par la nature mais
avant d'en arriver là arrêtons nous sur
la morphogénèse la morphogénèse c'est un
des phénomènes les plus fascinants du
vivant pensez-y
en l'espace de quelques jours ou de
quelques mois une cellule unique se
multiplient puis se complexifie jusqu'à
prendre la fin d'un organisme complet
qui peut être aussi sophistiqué que le
corps humain ses yeux son système
immunitaire et son cortex cérébral
comment est ce possible comment est ce
possible qu'une unique cellules
deviennent un être aussi sophistiquée
alors je vais parler que face à une
telle question
la dernière chose qui vous vient à
l'esprit ce sont les algorithmes et ça
c'est peut-être parce que pour nombre
d'entre vous se dresse une espèce de
grande muraille entre le monde du vivant
et le monde des algorithmes
si c'est le cas c'est bien dommage parce
que bien souvent voir le monde des
algorithmes avec les concepts de la
biologie ou al'inverse voir le monde du
vivant avec les concepts de
l'algorithmique c'est découvrir une
beauté cachée exquise quand j'observe la
morphogénèse je vois des unités de
calcul qui parviennent à communiquer
pour se dire toi tu fais la tête - les
bras lui les jambes et le plus fou c'est
que cette coordination se fait sans
autorité centrale
c'est à dire que contrairement ce que je
vient d'illustrer aucune cellule ne peut
devenir présidente et dicter aux autres
ce qu'elle doit faire
l'algorithme de la morphogénèse est un
algorithme décentralisée dit plus
simplement la morphogénèse c'est un peu
comme internet mais en super méga bien
foutu
en 1952 alan turing le père de
l'informatique est lé plus loin que ça
turing un postuler que les cellules
communique via des produits chimiques et
que la clé de la morphogénèse était la
production la diffusion et les
interactions entre ces produits
chimiques turing a montré que les cas
simpliste de sa théorie suffisait à
expliquer les zébrures et les tâches si
typique du vivant mais surtout les
simulations informatiques modernes a dit
de morphogénèse numérique suggère que
les cas plus sophistiqués de la théorie
de turing sont bel et bien à même
d'expliquer les merveilles de la
morphogénèse biologique
voir aussi étendre l'horizon des
possibles des designers de produits du
futur
aujourd'hui suite aux mathématiques de
turing à la biologie de la morphogénèse
et aux simulations numériques
on a une réponse univoque à notre
première question philosophique
oui l'ordre peut émerger sans autorité
la nature et parvient même à tout
instant de manière stupéfiante et nous
avons d'ailleurs encore beaucoup à
apprendre d'elle alors en disant ça je
vous rends compte qu'il ya un risque que
vous imaginiez que la nature peut
transcender les lois de la physique
intuitivement on envie de dire que le
système biologique sont beaucoup trop
complexe pour suivre des règles purement
mécanistiques dans les années 1940
le mathématicien john von neumann a
questionné ce postulat intuitif monomane
étant un théoricien il a complètement
ignoré les contraintes physico chimiques
pour un mathématicien la physique et la
chimie c'est déjà beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop compliqué il faut
simplifier monomanie imagina donc un
univers alternatif extrêmement simpliste
qui n'est autre qu'un immense
quadrillage chaque case peut-être dans
l'un des 29 états possibles ici
représentés par des couleurs ensuite à
chaque instant en fonction de l'état
présent de l'univers et de lois
physiques prédéterminé un nouvel état
physique de l'univers est calculé on dit
que l'univers de vollmann et
un automate cellulaire un automate
cellulaire c'est l'archétype d'un
univers purement mécanistiques et on
pourrait croire que dans un tel univers
le vivant n'a aucune chance d'apparaître
et pourtant monomane décrivit une
structure à l'intérieur de son univers
que l'on appelle désormais le
réplicateur de 20 noeuds man et dont
l'évolution était caractéristique du
vivant qu'est ce que van the man
entendez par là pour simplifier monomane
identifié à quatre propriétés du vivant
l'hérédité la variabilité la capacité à
toujours plus se complexifier et la
sélection even oman montra que son
indicateur purement mec mécanistiques
posséder toutes ses propriétés en fait
l'eau applicateur de 20 noeuds man ce
n'est pas tant la structure que l'on
voit là c'est surtout la longue bande en
dessous et cette longue bande ce code
génétique est long il est même super
super super long mais ils jouent un rôle
crucial en suivant mécanistiques mans
les lois imposées par son univers le
réplicateur devant naumann utilise son
code génétique pour fabriquer une
machine capable de copier coller le code
génétique leur épilateur peut ainsi se
répliquer mieux encore von neumann
montra que l'on pouvait modifier le code
génétique du réplicateurs sont toutefois
bouleverser le processus de réplication
y compris quand ces modifications
étaient d ajout de code génétique le
réplicateur de vernon manette est non
seulement capable de muter
il était aussi et surtout capable de se
complexifier imaginaire imaginez
maintenant ce réplicateurs proliférer à
travers l'univers de one man puis subir
des processus de sélection naturelle
le tout sur des milliers des milliards
voire des milliards de milliards de
génération et vous commencez à concevoir
comment l'incroyable sophistication du
vivant peut émerger de règles pourtant
purement mécanistiques mais c'était pas
ça le plus fou
le plus fou c'est que la réplication du
réalisateur de 20 no man repose sur le
même principe que la dn7 molécules du
vivant
sauf que souvenez vous on est là dans
les années 40 et la structure de l'adn
n'a pas encore été découverte à partir
d'une réflexion algorithmique purement
théorique bonne oman avait découvert
l'algorithme au coeur du vivant et il
avait vu étonnamment juste vous souvenez
de cette image on l'a vu le code
génétique du réplicateurs de vannes oman
est super super bon qu'en est il de la
dn7 molécules du vivant
l'équivalent biologique de la petite
structure que vous voyez à gauche et la
cellule qui contient l'adn pour l'humain
la taille de cette cellule se comptent
en micro m voici la longueur de l'adn
une fois celui-ci déroulé
l'adn humain fait autour de 2 m comme
pour leurs éducateurs de vin naumann le
code génétique de nos cellules et super
super bon il s'agit de la solution
algorithmique qui a trouvé la nature
pour permettre l'hérédité la variabilité
et la complexification ce qui aura
ensuite permis l'émergence de structures
aussi sophistiqué que le corps humain
ses yeux son système immunitaire et son
cortex cérébral le cortex cérébral
justement plus que le nombre de ses
composantes
ce qui me fascine particulièrement
vis-à-vis du cerveau humain c'est sa
faculté à apprendre
et ça ça nous amène à la troisième et
dernière question qu'est-ce qu'a prendre
aujourd'hui cette question
cette question fascine toutes sortes de
chercheurs les informaticiens devraient
rendre leur algorithme intelligent le
philosophe aimera garantir la fiabilité
des sciences et les étudiants aimerait
valider les examens sans aller en amphi
et là je ne peux m'empêcher de citer
l'un de mes grands héros le géant rei
solomonoff je cite en sciences mon
intérêt concerner davantage la manière
dont les choses étaient découvertes que
les contenus des découvertes l'oeuf doré
n'était pas aussi excitant que loi qui
les ponts den les contenus des
découvertes c'est bien mais effectué
pour effectuer des découvertes
c'est tellement plus fous et le génie de
solomonoff fut de découvrir le moteur
des découvertes en combinant
l'algorithmique avec une étrange
philosophie appelé le bail à nice mme
alors malheureusement je ne vais pas
avoir le temps de vous expliquer tout ça
en détail
et pourtant en tant que blizzard il faut
que j'en dis que c'est pas l'envié qui
me manque mais pour aujourd'hui je vais
me contenter du théorème de complétude
de solomonoff ce théorème dit que s'il
ya une régularité dans un jeu de données
alors l'algorithmique bayésienne de
solomonoff trouvera cette régularité à
coup sûr et ce avec étonnamment peu de
données
selon mme 9 ans revient donc à la
conclusion qu apprendre optimalement ou
effectué des découvertes
c'est à appliquer ces équations
pelvienne sauf que bien sûr vous allez
me dire que clairement en pratique on
n'applique pas les équations bazine de
solomonoff eh bien si depuis une petite
quinzaine d'années une machine learning
et les neurosciences ont énormément
progressé et ont découvert encore et
encore que des versions simplifiées de
l'algorithmique bayésienne de solomonoff
semble en fait être constamment
appliquée par nos cerveaux à tel point
qu'en 2012 le neuroscientifique
stanislas dehaene s'est vu contraint
d'enseigner un cours au collège de
france sur le sujet il a appelé son
cours
le cerveau statisticiens la révolution
bayésienne en sciences cognitives et il
avait tellement de choses à dire sur le
sujet qui s'est même senti obligé
d'étaler son cours
non pas sur deux jours non pas sur deux
mois mais sur deux ans incroyable en
optimisant les facultés d'apprentissage
de notre cerveau la nature semble avoir
découvert les équations bayésienne peu
seul au monde off
ce que je trouve fascinant dans tous les
cas qu'on a vu aujourd'hui mais aussi
dans de nombreux autres cas que je n'ai
pas le temps de présenter c'est qu'on ne
sait qu'on constate une convergence
entre des travaux humains ultra
théorique sur la nature des algorithmes
et leurs performances et les solutions
qui a trouvé le vivant pour proliférer
et survivre ce qu'il faut retenir ce que
la pensée algorithmique a énormément
apporté à l'étude du violon
mais aussi quelle inverse beaucoup de
nos problèmes algorithmiques ont sans
doute déjà été résolu par le vivant
mais surtout il ya quelque chose
d'absolument merveilleux je pense à
contempler le vivant avec les lentilles
de l'algorithmique comme le disait
richard feynman
je peux apprécier la beauté d'une fleur
en même temps je vois beaucoup plus que
la fleur je peux imaginer les cellules à
l'intérieur
les interactions complexes qui ont aussi
leur beauté tout comme la structure
interne et les processus je ne peux que
vous inviter à contempler vous aussi la
splendeur des algorithmes du vivant
merci
[Applaudissements]